hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play white finger
okay this is a game that was suggested
by you guys and I don't really know what
it's all about but for some right then
but for some reason um in the info
section I saw that it was referencing
quake so this might be built on a
modified version of the Oh what the hell
Jesus my shadow I was literally scared
by my own shadow what's wrong with me I
seem to be a woman of some sort the
ponytail version actually I would
believe that judging by the way the
model is held and the way it looks and
how twitchy it is I believe this is
probably quake 3 engine if I'm not
mistaken a modified version of it but
either way pretty cool and pretty nice
that it actually has some serious
lighting effects which of course the
quake engine did because ID is very good
about their engines but anyway this was
suggested by you guys don't know what
I'm getting myself into so here we go I
hear noises my mouth sensitive hi my
mouse sensitivity is quite low so it
takes me a lot to really clang oh my god
what the [ __ ] yeah
okay
all right then okay if you're gonna be
like that I should have realized that I
had a sprint button early on I didn't
know that there was gonna be a freaking
chainsaw man jumping out of nowhere
trying to nibble my giblets Jesus and he
turned on my volume I was loud I was not
expecting that okay so just run here cuz
f that guy Jesus Christ man I was like I
I heard a scream and then suddenly there
was chainsaw man okay is he gonna pop
out of somewhere I'm gonna sit here and
wait for him because I'm not ready for
that
that guy's like blew up my mic oh man
okay
so what's the deal what's the deal here
what do we got going on come on there it
is there it is
okay so maybe I don't know why he
triggered there and then and didn't
before I don't have a flashlight ain't
got nothing I don't know how long I was
wandering before any before of feeling
Suze I start moving he's gonna pop out
okay so this game definitely has me on
my toes if that's a good thing I don't
know what I'm looking for I don't know
what an objective of this game is so why
am I here or I seem to have I started in
a raw crap dead end I'm boned I would be
boned if he was chasing me he reminded
me of the Sham blur from like quake one
just cuz my mind is in quake mode right
now oh this is good
oh this big empty room is definitely
good this is over here what do we got is
this a way out did I warn dude dude ah
the doors locked of course it is didn't
think it was gonna be that easy
weird running sound comes I need to I
guess I need to just wander around in
these rooms until I find a key probably
grab a B I don't know wish I had a
flashlight or something cuz it is hard
to see oh this is where I start no this
is this isn't where I started this is a
different dungeon room so I was locked
up I wouldn't be a key in the done trim
then wouldn't keep a key there so I was
locked up
I escaped
or maybe he let me out because he wanted
some sport ah no nothing they're locked
up locker haha [ __ ] out ah [ __ ] up
I can't sprint very far yeah
Oh piss like a nice Jesus balls get off
of me
this is where I started [ __ ] run you
stupid a home run I'm not running I'm
not running I'm dead I'm so dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm oh
I'm bleeding I'm bleeding bad oh this is
not good
I'm bleeding real bad I didn't know that
I was just trailing blood that makes it
easy for him to follow me that's for
sure no wonder I couldn't sprint I
didn't have anything left to sprint with
all my bones were floppy out of blood
loss that's how it works that's how
science works your bones become floppy
and then you can't do anything what's
that oh it's a Dickey who Dickie baby oh
yeah I got my mind game I must save my
run juice until I can get it okay I just
need to find how to get back to where I
was I think it was down there's all
weight to the left but I'm not exactly
sure was it
am I still bleeding I'm not gonna look
back to check no I think it was down
this hall because I remember the
flickering light and then I took a left
at the next left I believe right here or
the next one there is no next one so
it's got to be here yeah yeah ha ha ha
ah go go go go go go lady go go go go go
go go go go go go
Oh
hey I won the game just exited haha the
game exited like okay alright um I guess
that's it then tow thank you haha
alright
I'm link to the game is in the
description below um you could try for
yourself
I was pretty intense I mean it really
sucks because like when I wanted to run
I couldn't run and I thought every time
the screen flashed that was like him
getting me like stabbing me in the back
and was ahh oh hello
and then no but anyway so yeah I'm
pretty good short but good I don't see
many games made on a quake engine if
that really was made on the quake engine
of which version I have no idea but I
think some maybe quick - or something I
don't even know old old that's for sure
but anyway thank you everybody so much
watching click the annotation more
videos it I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video bye
Oh
ah
bud
Oh
goodbye
and